columnist Sebastian Mallaby profiles
World Bank President James Wolfensohn in
the new book the world's banker
Wednesday the author sat down with the
wall street journal's david wessel at
the Council on Foreign Relations the
program's an hour
good morning welcome to this very
special event where I get a chance to
pick at sebastian's book and he has to
respond I can't promise you it'll be as
much fun as the vice presidential
debates but I'll do my part if if
Sebastian does his I want to thank the
council for asking me to do this because
it forced me to do something that is too
easy to put off which is read a book you
mean to read and I really enjoyed
reading Sebastian's book in journalism
editors sometimes refer to stories as
dbi dull but important and it's probably
not true in this room but in most
American newspapers the World Bank is
right up there in the top five d by a
TBI topics and what Sebastian has done
in this book is discovered that there's
a wonderful character at the center of
the world bank Jim Wolfensohn and made
it quite easy to read the book so I i
recommend it to all of you and i'm not
saying that just because I happen to be
sitting here Sebastian as many of you
know has been a Washington Post
columnist since 1999 before that he
spent 13 years on the staff of the
Economist in Zimbabwe and London Japan
and then finally in Washington he was
trained in Oxford but he where he
obviously learned a lot but he writes in
the back of the book that he also
prepared for this assignment after
college by working for two months as a
truck drivers assistant in Chile after
which he rode buses up the Western spine
of South America through Peru Ecuador
Bolivia and Brazil and once even read
his own name on a missing persons notice
in Peru but fortunately he was found now
if any of you've ever been asked to
moderate one of these Council on Foreign
Relations events you will know that this
turns out to be the single most
organized Institution in Washington if
the Council on Foreign Relations ran
Homeland Security we wouldn't have to
worry about terrorism anymore so I'm
instructed to tell you that you should
turn off your cell phones that unlike
most council meetings this one is on the
record that will begin first with about
20-25 minutes of question
by me and answers by Sebastian and then
we'll open it up for questions from
those of you who are in the audience and
I'm going to read this one verbatim we
will end promptly at nine thirty am and
as a courtesy to our speakers we ask
that you not leave the meeting early and
seeing how organized the council as I'm
sure there will be some penalty be paid
if you dare step out the door before
then Sebastian let me start by asking
you to describe a little bit what you
mean when you write in the book that Jim
Wolfensohn subscribes to the hand
grenade theory of Management okay well
first of all I'd like to thank the folks
here at Case Western University from
organizing yesterday No No thank you to
the Council on Foreign Relations when I
meant to say the hand grenade theory of
management when wolfson came to the bank
in 1995 he came out of the private
sector he'd been a banker he'd be run
his own private bank for a long time in
Wall Street and before that he'd been at
Salomon Brothers and made his name by
leading the Chrysler bailout in 1979 now
the atmosphere Salomon Brothers you can
imagine from liars poker I mean it was
not a kind of polite you know a sort of
softly spoken sort of players there were
morning meetings as wilkinson describes
them where you know the cigar ash would
be flying the cursors would be loud the
coffee would be spilt all over the place
and be a really humdinger of a fight and
then at lunchtime a client would come in
from the outside and all the partners
who had been throwing coffee at each
other in the morning would suddenly kind
of line up they'd all be totally as we
know Polina their kind of team team and
when Wolfensohn came to the World Bank
he sort of brought some of that style
which i think is as personal style
anyway to the job of running the World
Bank of public institution now the
difference is that if you yell at people
and throw stuff at them and so forth and
then at Christmas time they get a bonus
which is in you know the six or seven
figures they're kind of okay with that
but at the World Bank if you yell at
people and they've got economics PhDs
and they're not going to get any bonus
they kind of say well what do you know
about development and so he there was
this clash between this larger than life
kind of tornado figure and it's very
proud institution the World Bank and
Wilkinson was sort of soda time to shake
it up that it kind of felt like a hand
grenade being lobbed right into the
middle of the building and do you think
that the bank needed a little bit of
that well one of the toughest things
when i was doing this book was to figure
out you know what would wear the truth
lay and in how much the institution did
need a shake-up how much it didn't and i
think what was going on in the 90s is
that you know that there was some need
for some discreet things to be fixed but
in 1995 when Wilson came in the next
couple of years remember we were going
through the financial the financial
bubble was was starting to inflate the
private sectors prestige were selling
all-time high so you had not only a
financial bubble but kind of
psychological bubble as to what people
believed private sector efficiency
really was and so there was a perception
that you know you come to the World Bank
you can import that private sector
prowess apply it to a public sector
institution and zing this thing will you
know get up and start doing
extraordinary stuff that it never did
before well I mean you know it doesn't
work like that the World Bank has a
board that meets twice a week formerly
informally on other days as well and a
no private sector institution could be
lean mean and fast if it had that kind
of oversight with multiple mandates and
so forth so I think that Wilkinson
greatly exaggerated how much the bank
needed the hand grenade treatment and he
said a broke a lot of heads trying to
fix something which couldn't be fixed as
much as he really thought it it could
now one chapter in the book which is
actually quite moving is your
description of the World Bank in Bosnia
and what struck me was that it was a
model of doing the right thing at the
right time and not relying on the
cookbook I wonder if you could talk a
little bit about that and then draw the
contrast if you will to the world bank
roll in Iraq which certainly needs some
fixing as well right well both near was
a remarkable case and because the world
i got into Bosnia extremely earlier it
be the first mission into Bosnia went in
sort of within days of the ceasefire
being announced in October
1995 and even before that there'd been
meetings but where where the Bosnian
Muslim leaders had escaped out of
Sarajevo through a tunnel which went
under the airport and climbed up the
mountains and got to Poland where there
were meetings with on reconstruction
with world bank officials so there's
this early bond with these besieged
bosniak leaders with the World Bank team
was was extremely committed to acting
fast once the ceasefire came the World
Bank director for that part of the world
was at the Dayton Peace Accords and I
actually think that the Peace Accords
would not have happened if it hadn't
been for her presence because every time
the Bosnian Muslims wanted to walk out
you know the character kind of keep them
at the table was here's the World Bank
you know they've risked their lives
these people by flying into your capital
when the snipers are still in action and
if you sign this peace deal they are
committed to delivering serious
reconstruction and you make the point
that this was a deliberate strategy on
by Holbrook you think that's right i
mean Holbrook and David Lipton at the
Treasury at the time had brought the
bank in very early to to get that to get
that to happen and it helped that you
know in the Clinton Treasury there was
not only Larry Summers who had been the
chief economist of the World Bank but
David Lipton who'd be at the
international monetary fund new these
institutions inside out knew exactly had
to push their buttons and make them do
things which would promote US interests
and and so they could do that very early
on now the contrast with Iraq is that
when it came time to plan reconstruction
the bush Treasury was slower in
approaching the bank and less good at
doing it kind of informally at first
making a contact which would not be seen
as presumptions it's been argued to me
by the current Treasury that look we
couldn't go to the World Bank until
after the war so you have to do the
invasion first and then you do the
reconstruction well I mean you could do
parallel planning if you've got the kind
of relationship between the US Treasury
in the world bank that enables the
United States to use this institution as
a tool of American foreign policy it
doesn't happen unless you sort of know
how
do it now in the book you make the point
that the World Bank basically has two
big businesses one is lending to
countries the basically could borrow on
their own Brazil India and China they
make money on that which they use to
finance their operations and the other
is the basically loans to very poor
countries the so-called ida program some
of the loans ever get paid back some
people think they ought to be declared
grants in the first place and it's a
very delicate balance the first requires
a good credit rating so you could borrow
money to lend to China the second
requires the largesse of the Congress
and the parliaments around the world is
this a sustainable model or is it under
attack now well there are two sources of
threat to this model on the commercial
lending side the lending to countries
like Brazil China which which can go to
the private capital markets the problem
is that traditionally the bank has been
able to lend to those countries because
it has a triple-a credit rating and it
it's not trying to make a profit to
trying to cover its costs but not make a
profit so it lends the small spread over
its cost of capital and that's cheaper
than Citigroup would learn to these
countries but the thing is that the
World Bank has become so cautious and
careful about dotting every I and
crossing every T when it comes to
getting the environmental impact study
right getting the social impact study
right so that if you do it down or
something you know the people who have
moved or treated properly and all of
these very good values which have been
built into bank projects have been
pushed to the extent that it can take
years and years and years to get the
project off the ground and at a certain
point the burrowers say look you know
I'd rather borrow from Citigroup and pay
a bit more on my money but do the
project twice as quickly so that's the
threat on on that commercial business
and you see it in the numbers that the
portfolio has declined a lot in the last
five or seven years and that was
disguised for a while by the asian
financial crisis where there was a lot
of non project lending but basically
there is there is a medium-term threat
which the bank is trying to fix by
speeding itself up but so long as
there's a lot of pressure from civil
society
to be extra careful on these
environmental and social issues it's not
clear the bank and escape that box on
the other side you're right that with
the soft loans the idol owns these are
to the very very poor countries which
often wind up not being able to repay
and we've now had already two rounds of
debt relief in 1996 was epic one 1999 k
mythic to and now the annual meetings
just finished we've had discussion of a
third round of debt relief for these
same borrowers at a certain point if you
lend money and then you don't get paid
back and you forgive it you have to call
a ground a Grammy nadina is basically a
ground and you should call it that but
if you do that that raises questions
about you know you're depriving yourself
of the money you would have been paid
back and so there's a hole in your
balance sheet and so there's a threat to
that side of the operation to now some
people would say well so what it's a
good news that the world capital markets
have evolved and emerging markets are
now able to borrow and maybe the World
Bank has outlived its usefulness in
those things I mean and then so why
should we worry if the World Bank is
forced to shrink because the markets
have found ways to do what it was set up
to do well i think you know in good
times that argument has a seven Clause
ability you know you could say that as
long as China can borrow from Citigroup
the government can issue you know bombs
and in Europe and raise money if it
wants to finance anti-poverty projects
it can raise the money and spend that
money on water systems for poor people
if it doesn't want to do that
commercially that means is not really
motivated so why should we kid ourselves
that a public institution giving them
the money will really change their
motivation so I think that's the
plausible case but there are 22 whether
big qualifiers one is that you do get
stuff like the asian financial crisis or
brazil's crisis or russia's crisis right
where it actually is important for
Western interests to be able to
stabilize countries that are falling
apart and having an institution with a
very large balance sheet and a lot of
capital it can throw in two backup IMF
led bailouts is a useful policy tool and
I don't see why we should get rid of it
I mean it's not costing us everything
this commercial side of the
of the operation doesn't cost taxpayers
anything so so why get rid of it and the
second thing is just sort of intuitively
I mean you had this institution which
has been around now for 60 years which
has done projects in 100 countries which
is the biggest sort of concentration of
thinking and expertise and
sophistication on the toughest problems
that we will face you know from AIDS to
you know what you do about institution
building all these things it's the
biggest source of sort of via public
goods creation in this field what why
mess with it what you know I mean you
can argue that it's not as neat as it
was before but I see no cost in keeping
it on now I suppose the real test though
is our poor people around the world
better off for the World Bank and in
particular are poor people better off
because of the things that Jim
Wolfensohn did at the bank or not well
you know at the core of your question is
one of the toughest things about
development and about defending
development in front of you know
skeptical rightly skeptical taxpayers
because the truth about development is
that you know it's a partnership always
between the external actors that donors
the World Bank or USAID or wherever and
and the domestic players the politicians
who are actually implementing policy in
these countries so if you look at a
country like Uganda as I do in my book
which cut poverty by forty percent in
the 1990s and you ask you know what did
the World Bank do and I ask this
question to every policy maker on the
again inside the dealt with a bank and
every bank personally dealt with Uganda
and with other donors as well who are
into the mix and so on I mean I took it
from all angles trying to isolate what
did the World Bank do and the answer is
that the big picture of progress of
forty percent platen poverty is clearly
done by Ugandan policymakers and this is
a great character in this chapter called
Emmanuel to miss a memo to Billy who is
this larger-than-life sort of
hard-drinking TAF brilliant technocrats
who basically ran the finance ministry
during this period and he didn't take
nonsense from any donor he told him to
get lost if he didn't agree with her
advice and he drove Uganda's progress
and I give him you know most of the
credit and but that does
mean that the world that was unimportant
because he couldn't have done everything
he did if the bank hadn't come in and
given him money quickly when he wanted
to do universal primary education you
know he couldn't have done something
which is an extraordinary lavigne yet
where they wanted to figure the World
Bank wanted to figure out what happened
to local schools how come they weren't
increasing enrollment whereas the
government central government's budget
seem to be transferring money to these
local schools where did the money go so
the World Bank designed a survey where
they looked at the world at the central
government's books figure out how much
money was supposed to go to each school
send surveyors to go ask the school's
how much they've gotten and figured out
that the median school in the survey had
got zero zero percent gir to them
because it had all been ripped off by
the middle level of the government and
then this information was posted on the
doors of the schoolrooms saying you
should have gotten this much and they
resurveyed five years later and had gone
up to seventy percent or something now
that's an example of a sort of technical
thing which took a World Bank person who
knew how to do spreadsheets knew how to
design surveys knew how to crunch
numbers and so that lets you find useful
micro examples of how the technical
expertise can change things but most the
time it's a partnership you know if
something good happens partly it's the
government the dirty part is the World
Bank that did it partly at some visiting
economist from Harvard who haven't have
an idea i mean it's terribly difficult
to put your finger on it and that's why
when Paul O'Neill or somebody I dad says
and they'll show me what you've done it
can be hard to come up with a sort of
crisp answer now one of the things that
you described quite well as how
Wolfensohn forced the bank to stop
looking at nongovernmental organizations
ngos as if they were the enemy and to
somehow smaller them with love in the
hopes that they would appreciate that in
the end actually they had similar goals
to the bank which is not wasn't set up
of course to destroy environments order
enrich bondholders but to help poor
people but as you point out in the book
perhaps the romance of the NGO the
disinterested only out for the good of
the people NGO is one that we in the
press have created and isn't justified
by the
yeah I mean I think you can see the
World Bank in this period starting about
10 years ago as kind of a case study in
what you do about being encircled by a
critical civil society in 1994 we didn't
have the term anti-globalization
protests but we had the reality of them
and that's what happened at the World
Bank's 50th anniversary meetings in
Madrid the cry was 50 years is enough
the Madrid annual meetings descended
into complete chaos and then nine months
later along comes wolfensohn as the New
World Bank president and makes it his
absolutely top priority to reach out to
these critics to bring them into the
tent to try and you know see what they
want and give them what's reasonable and
kind of create a piece and he did this
party in personal ways and he has you
know he is a guy who made more than 100
million dollars on Wall Street by
winning people over and doing deals and
he's pretty good at this and there was a
particular case of Bruce rich from the
Environmental Defense Fund who had
written a book attacking the bank the
year before Wolfensohn arrived and the
World Bank's external relations
department had prepared a long memo
saying why all of this was wrong and it
was nonsense and so forth and when
Wolfensohn came in he invited Bruce rich
to his supper to his house for dinner
and sort of you know brought him in and
Buddha's vice presence there to listen
and really made an effort to convey the
idea that the bank was going to listen
to these critics and he was done in
substantive ways as well so that in 1999
it was decreed that if you want to get
soft learn soft loans in the World Bank
your country has to have a development
plan which is created by a participatory
process bringing you know the NGOs to
the table so that they can have their
input and it's hard to think of new what
more an institution could do and yet you
know whence the Seattle protests broke
out in November or December of 1999 I
remember reading in places that you know
other in students like the working world
trade organization and I got it in the
neck International Monetary Fund would
be next but the World Bank had spent
five years building bridges world bank
would be okay was it okay no spring
meetings of 2000 is totally encircled by
protesters order meetings of 2000 again
complete chaos and meanwhile the actual
projects at the bank do and I have some
quite juicy examples in the book are
also being attacked by civil society and
that's you know and in a way that
suggests that they didn't always you
know take into account the fact that
efforts towards the environment to
displace people so forth have been
greatly improved so I think that you
know what this teaches is that you can't
expect to make complete peace with NGOs
and that you have to sometimes be
critical about you know you can't sir
from the presumption that you know the
quislings are all reasonable that you
can win people over if you're any
reasonable yourself and I do think that
the media and sort of congressional
staffers need to treat what civil
society says well NGO say with a bit
more skepticism than they traditionally
do now my final question this is my
favorite passage in the book and for
those of you who will never read the
whole thing I is page 170 and 171 and
you describe in November 1997 the French
representative on the bank board is
leaving and he turns out to be less than
enthusiastic about Jim Wolfensohn
leadership and you describe him giving
it what I'm sure was a very articulate
speech and I hope it was recorded on
video because I'd love to see it with
the original French accent and finally
when he reaches his climax he says could
we think of a better analogy allegory of
the bank than narcissus the handsome
self infatuated doomed hero of Greek
mythology who drowned himself while
kissing his own image reflected in the
water he looked around at his colleagues
he recites a poem Ottoman left his poem
hanging out there in the air without
saying what he meant by it the figures
around the table seemed to freeze and so
on you can read the rest well my
question to you is what is it like to
write a book about a guy who has this
kind of reputation with his colleagues
well it was a you know the on this
project with basically an interest in
development which going back 20 years
traveling around Latin America and so
forth being The Economist correspondent
in Africa for a while and and so on and
and then the second impulse was where
after nine eleven the concern for failed
States is not just a sort of minority
interest there might be a bigger
audience for a book about development
issues but as I got into the project I
realize that my central character Jim
Wolfensohn it was this extraordinary mix
of you know amazingly positive qualities
and then some quite serious negative
ones and as I went around talking to
people you know two hundred interviews
of people who sort of interacted with
him you know i would get long speeches
about how this was the most charming
committed wonderful person they'd ever
met who really cares about the fact that
half of humanity lives on two dollars a
day and he has this you know he's the
year and you try to have that and then
also this is a psychopath erm narcissist
you know that they are extreme and when
I gave the manuscript to a friend at one
point he read it and said he couldn't
figure out which of these ones was most
dominant was it on the one hand a sort
of noble figure like Ben Kingsley or was
it Danny DeVito and and the thing is
that you know he is both and the process
of following him and was you know with
was importing there's one of the stories
which I like to tell us right when I was
beginning the research I wanted to get
some access to him and sort of you know
get to meet him and I was told what if
you want to meet him please go to
Canterbury which I thought was slightly
strange because you know he's in
Washington I'm in Washington we could
just meet him Washington but no go to
can't do it so I flew to London and went
to Canterbury and in the in the shadow
of the cathedral there there was a
little seminar room and I walked in and
there at the head of the table hosting a
seminar was Jim Wolfensohn sitting next
to the Archbishop of Canterbury with his
purple shared and next to the Archbishop
of Canterbury there was swami agnivesh
with a orange tab and hindu mystic and
nexus for me agnivesh there was born
with black sunglasses and I think of
anybody who can put this kind of
coalition together is not a boring guy
and it was a great experience trying to
figure out his psychology extreme in
both directions while I was doing the
book well thank you I think we want to
turn open it up to questions there's a
mic floating around and you should use
it especially for c-span please stand
when you ask a question
give us your name and your affiliation
and remember the idea is to ask
questions not to give speeches would
anybody like to go first or else you'll
have to hear me talk somewhere please
the woman here Hattie Babbitt from hunt
alternatives fun you said that in the
beginning that the toughest job was
sifting through the facts to find out
where the truth lie having done that
what should the next World Bank
president do I mean what did you learn
about the functioning of the bank as
opposed to the functioning of Jim
Wolfensohn that would guide the next
president well I think the first thing
to say is that there are certain
qualities the next World Bank president
ought to have you need to be a fantastic
communicator because the bank remains
that institution under siege from
critics of all kinds and you need
wolfensohn style communication skills
and some people like the previous
president blue Preston did not have
those and that was a significant problem
the second thing you need is to be able
to manage a big public sector
institution which is different to a
private sector one and so I think
somebody with experience of doing that
it is important and the third thing you
want is somebody who actually has spent
some time thinking about development who
is fluent already in the concepts and
doesn't kind of have come to it with a
reinvent the wheel the kind of idea
because you can waste enormous amounts
of time by kind of arriving and say I
know what microcredit or I know what
it's all about girls education because
these things have been around and
wasting time sort of you know on these
silver bullets is is a big big pitfall
in development happens all the time so I
think those are the three qualities that
one needs to look for and I'd say that
my big strategic advice to the next
president the World Bank and this is
sort of will be a live question fairly
soon because Wilkinson's term is up at
the end of May next year is essentially
look you've got a choice on the one hand
you've got these northerners both civil
society and governments giving you
mandates all the tram time to trying to
make you kind of the secretariat of
northern ambitions and so that the g7
will meet every year and say this year
guys know the thing is hiv/aids and then
they'll meet the next year and they'll
say no
other thing is that we absolutely have
to do something about girls education
and the next year it will be we're very
worried about those front nine states
around Afghanistan please can you do
something about des and it'll go on like
that and meanwhile civil society will be
saying no damage to Tibet no damage to
rain forests no damage to environment
never know and and you know you can't
just ignore that stuff because you do
need the IDA replenishments though the
money for the soft line window every
three years but your real job in so far
as you can is to chill them out chill
the mad and focus on the borrowers on
the poor countries are meant to be
helping go to them and say what is a we
can do to help you and then try and
deliver the best technical advice you
can to these poor countries so that if
you imagine the bank as a circle with
these two mills and stakeholders on the
top and the southern burrowers the
pallbearers on the bottom try to close
your ears to the north as much as
possible and focus on on the people you
should really be helping thank you
gentlemen here in the aisle for app and
her question sigma d like Sigmund
Nagurski center for international
leadership a following question you have
identified Wolfensohn was the back for
the next president it would be very
difficult to go into his shoes and try
to follow the pattern but one thing
which I don't know I haven't read the
book I read under the reviews one thing
which was missing in what what you said
was the fact that orphans are brought
passion to his job passion and complete
commitment to the issue of development
and this is where the negative parts
come a passionate person a creative
person he is because he's a musician as
well occasionally loses his patience and
as you know very well being a journalist
yourself when you lose your patient you
have to control yourself well it was
very difficult to control yourself when
you are on top of the pile and he was on
top of the pilot he is so i think that
the justice to
Oh what fence on unto the bank would be
for you to say he has a passion he is
excused for his negative aspects but he
has contributed to the development took
a great degree and the legacy of
Wolfensohn for the next guy would be
calm was passion maybe control it but
don't be a bureaucrat and faceless
individual i would say once you pass the
mic over here i would say that you don't
need to read the book because you've
pretty much absorbed it and summarized
it much better than I did there's a lot
of truth in that I mean what you say I
mean he did definitely come to the job
with passion there's a great quote which
he gave in a profile in the Financial
Times after a year so in the job where
he said you know developments like a
love a new love I wake up in the morning
thinking about it I go to bed at night
thinking about it it's a passion that
grows me anticipates a romantic romantic
attachment to this thing and you know he
is absolutely worked up about the fact
that this is the biggest and justice in
the world he is tacking the biggest and
most pressing and most morally
compelling issues in the world I totally
agree with you that he has that enormous
passion and I think it is great now he
also has some negatives he has a temper
he has a thin skin and so forth and that
sometimes got in the way of a good
judgment and made him a less effective
president than he could have been now
what's the net I say to people sometimes
look Wilkinson is like a current account
surplus you know he's net positive right
but there are two enormous great big
numbers up here and the negative is
quite big even if the positive is even
bigger that's that's how I think I would
think about the first time I ever hurt
we have the mic to poster and it's the
first time ever heard anybody used the
current account surplus as a metaphor to
explain someone's impact on society
hollister in the star group I'd like to
hear more about corruption and how mr.
Wolfensohn and deals with corruption in
these countries when the corruption is
at the very top he has to be concerned
about currying favor both with the US
administration which is concerned about
frontline States and as you said the g7
if it's the flavor of the of the year to
be concerned about frontline States he
also has to be concerned about thinking
about being reappointed and he also has
to be concerned about getting the World
Bank's bigger message about development
and fighting corruption through to some
of these heads of state how do you think
he's handled himself on that and do you
have suggestions about how had he
suggested a long lines a future world
bank president would deal with this very
ugly issue of corruption right that's a
great question and it's no opening into
a lot of things in the book you know to
the extent that there's a sort of an
intellectual quest novel and the quest
is no how do you had you turn a sliver
of the rich world's wealth into progress
against poverty the quest takes you in
you know kind of if you think about
development in the big sweep of history
you know you start off in the 50s doing
physical infrastructure for the physical
capital then in the 60s and 70s it
becomes human capital so health
education then by the 90s has become
social capital so it's about
institutions had a function getting
participation right accountability
transparency and corruption is a central
part of that and one of the things that
wolfington did is that he did make a
speech about the cancer of corruption in
the fall of 1996 and put it on the map
in a way that I think it had been a
little bit on the McNamara but it had
definitely faded out by the early 90s
there were also the stories about world
bank officials wanting to talk about
corruption in the early 90s and being
told by the general counsel of the bank
that you can't do that that the articles
of agreement
the bank's say this is an economic
institution do not mention the c-word
and when Wolfensohn came into office he
said I'm going to talk about corruption
and he started near you can't do that
you say I'm the president I'll do what I
want and he did it he heatley so I give
him I give him credit for that in the
book but the tough issue is so how do
you how to implement that and my case
study on that is Indonesia where you
know he came in 95 and went to Jakarta
in 96 and came back saying look this is
out of control I mean we used to have a
situation where the president's wife
Madame 10 was joked about Madame ten
percent right but no its way over ten
percent and the all the kids are
stealing money hand over fist you know
this is ridiculous but the problem was
that the bank's country team in
Indonesia we're having a debate about
the same issue you know should we
confront the Indonesian how much should
we should we threaten to pull loans if
they don't do something about this
corruption and the verdict of the
experts dealing with Indonesia was look
this country is cutting poverty by
hundreds of thousands of people per year
I mean an extraordinary rate of progress
grants but I mean Oxfam in 1994 put out
a paper on in the Indonesian model for
cutting poverty I mean it was the
darling of poverty so do we really want
to pull out of this country which is
doing such fantastic isn't corruption in
the grand scale of things kind of like
saying that you know your education
policy isn't that great because you're
spending too much on high schools not
enough in primary schools and exactly we
didn't like the corruption but I mean it
is the fact that twenty five percent of
your money is ripped off in a particular
project worse or better than if you go
to India and you make the same loan they
don't rip off that much but the whole
project fails because nobody builds the
you know the road you're trying to make
or something so that was the thinking
and I think the Indonesian team kind of
for understandable reasons decided
corruption is bad but not so bad that
we're going to get out of here will
really really lay down you know throw
down the gauntlet then of course the
1997 the financial crisis starts 1998 so
how does thrown out of power you know
primarily because the corruption I mean
the financial crisis didn't begin
because of corruption but I explained in
the book that it could not be
trolled because the institutions of
state were so corrupt in Indonesia but
there was every time you try to get a
handle on on the financial staff you
know the money was flying out of the
back of the central bank to you know so
how to his friends and any kind of
monetary policy was on the moon by that
so so corruption was proven to be you
know on the level of sort of
hyperinflation of something something
which is so serious to your development
prospects that it basically wipes out
everything else and probably they should
have pulled that but telling that before
the fact is incredibly hard and I think
that's the issue with corruption is not
just oh it's tough to go to a head of
state and say you're corrupt because
well as an actually did that the issue
is more so what do you do no dude duple
I do know that that's the hard thing
it's a question over here Jon Alterman
CSIS want to ask you about the culture
of the bank my friends at the bank
complained to me not only is the bank
bureaucratic in many ways but because
it's populated by so many third world
elites its bureaucratic in third world
kind of ways there are managers who are
micromanagers they're secretive they're
not open to ideas that that there's
something wrong about the institution
partly because of who the institution
grows out of is it your sense that there
is something wrong with the culture of
the place how much can the president do
to change that and how successful is
Wolfensohn been at addressing those
kinds of problems yeah I mean there's
some truth of that and that was
definitely in a big way his perception
when he arrived and that's why he would
walk down the corridor in his early days
and it cost some you know a random
manager and say I'm surprised you're
still here and then leave the guy to
figure out if he just been fired or
something I mean he that was the hand
grenade theory of Management he really
shook it up I mean playing out half the
senior staff left or I mean huge numbers
of people were pushed out I mean really
confrontational attempt to fix the
problem you described now the fact that
you're still describing it it tells you
something about whether it's possible to
really fix it and whether it's smart to
kind of turn the institution upside down
shake it very hard and then kick it in
hope of improving it if you don't
improve it after all that you've caused
a lot of disruption without so what
about didn't he move
a lot of people out of Washington into
the borrowing countries yeah that that
that was a very good innovation when he
began all the country directors who were
the kind of key people controlling the
budget were based in headquarters by now
something like two thirds are out in the
field that is a big improvement because
it makes it more likely that the thing I
described earlier about chilling at the
north and listening to the SAT is going
to happen if your if your directors
actually based in the field I think they
put the relationship with the host
government and trying to help that house
government higher up on their agenda so
that was a very good innovation over
here in the pink shirt mark Leland mark
Leland associate well I'm an old friend
of Jim's and and and I'm on the side of
the admirers of the passion I think one
of the things was I remember I was at
the Treasury of the early 80s and Reagan
he wanted to be head of the World Bank
in 1980 we actually worked on it and he
had became an American citizen is great
expense actually and he didn't have a
lot of money I mean one talks about he
made the money after we always say one
of the luckiest things for him was it
didn't happen but he then had many much
more experience so it is a passion of
his of something he wanted to do my
question and I kind of watched it I mean
the one thing those of us who were for
him was that was the one element you
didn't mention in your answer about the
next president which is the private
sector I mean the one thing about Jim
which was not a barber carnival and we I
mean I don't know how much you do go
into the book because I waited to hear
you till I read it he didn't really want
me to buy it but I bought it a good
friendship comes to an end but I will
and I will I will absorb it but looking
at this because the one factor I mean
one of the things in the Reagan
administration you worked was trying to
get co-financing which I gather from
your earlier answer working with the
World Bank is so bureaucratic you said
that that was one of these kind of
things that one gave up but the great
hope for him was to promote the private
sector to kind of shake it up that there
would be a greater involvement now of
course I sometimes jokingly say that he
should have the job mark malloch-brown
has and Mark malloch-brown should have
the job he has because mark is really
working on private sector initiatives in
the UNDP and you are what I'm trying to
get at in my question is how important
do you think the World Bank's role in
promoting the private sector is and how
well do you think jim has accomplished
that because I think we have no question
as to his passion and no question is to
the fact that he really was trying to do
I think you don't either i'm asking this
as a question that he was really trying
to do something and it's hard to do it
in an institution that it's you know we
all that very hard to fire anybody so
when you you gave a description of
somebody that to me may frighten me i
mean this is just going to be a public
sector kind of guy that spent his career
in development and so forth and if he
gets into that kind of bank where
everybody else is like that what's he
going to do well i mean if the question
is you know how many partnerships can
the bank for the private sector in the
third world doing projects together then
I think you know there's lots of scope
for that because I mean I have an
example of this remember with the Chad
Cameron pipeline X I wanted to develop
oil and Chad but the political risk of
investing in Chad was enormous and you
couldn't get any commercial bank to lend
to you to do a pipeline in this country
which was unstable and so forth and you
could be expropriated national I went
here so therefore they came to the World
Bank on the theory that if the World
Bank put skin in the game then for the
Chadian government to come and
nationalize you will be kind of tricky
because then you'll be cutting off all
your aid access all your donors would
walk out the door and so they the World
Bank did come on come in on that and
they also came in because the other
political risk was civil society
criticism on the environment and so
forth and Exxon realized that if you had
the bank involved in sort of a bank
environmental standards imposed on this
pipeline it would be much easier to
defend it in the public forum and so you
had this partnership between you know
the kind of slightly slower bureaucracy
with all its sort of you know careful
caution and it kind of gung-ho private
sector opera
which worked pretty well and when I went
a chair to look at this thing you know
you arrived in the middle of nowhere and
it looks as if you know magic carpet
somewhere outside of Houston has been
you know flown all the way like that
landed in the middle of Africa in this
landlocked country and there are these
big guys with training accents and oil
derricks and so forth and and I mean the
awesome power of a determined
multinational when it wants to make
something happen yeah there's no
transport in Chad you can't get from the
capital to the oil site what do they do
they have a private air service to bring
people there's no Road so they build a
road you know any problem that excellent
confronted basically fixed in short
order and that was a terrific
combination the project off the ground
partly because of this muscle and this
focus of Exxon and partly because of the
political skills of the World Bank and
that was a good combination it has been
happening a bit and I think you know to
your question one of the things we've
seen recently is that the equator
principles developed by the
International Finance Corporation which
is part of the World Bank of course have
been adopted by commercial banks so that
future lending in these controversial
projects will be on standards which had
been effectively developed by the Jim
Wolfensohn World Bank's I think he has
made some strides in that area well
engine-wise does he think the next
Persian be private sector yeah yeah I
you know I have mixed feelings about
that i mean i can i can see why you
think that you know you you want the
private sector energy and so forth you
don't want to have a bureaucrat on top
of a bureaucratic organization but i
personally think that the costs of
having a private sector person who comes
in thinking that this can be run like a
private sir it's not mckenzie it's not
goldman sachs it never will be and if
you think it can be you're going to
waste a lot of time bang your head
against a wall and trying to do stuff
which just didn't mean you know people
don't understand that the governance
problems the bureaucracy about the bank
and so forth is largely driven
externally is the fact that you have
civil society with its foot on your neck
is the fact that you have shoulders with
its foot on your neck this is why you
can't run a public
organization like Goldman Sachs and
people who don't get that waste a lot of
time on the aisle there allen went could
you tell us something about Bullen sins
attitude towards the IFC and the role
the IFC has played under his tenure I
asked the question because I've heard it
suggested that under Wolfensohn the IFC
has been pushed more and more and into
questionable projects that is projects
that really wouldn't meet the standards
of a bank lending on basically
commercial terms which is what the IFC
does this under Peter void kahoo I
believe was brought into the IFC by
Wolfensohn I don't know if you address
this in your book I haven't read it yet
but what could you tell us about the
role of the IFC in willful sins thinking
for people don't know when to just give
the two sentence explanation of what the
International Finance Court is sure well
I mean the two other parts of the world
bank the soft loan window in the
commercial land window have it in common
that they only lent a government's
whereas the IFC can lend directly to
private sector projects and that's how
it's the International Finance
Corporation and it's supposed to you
know put money into stuff like the Chad
camera and pipeline where it can lend to
a consortium as opposed to a central
government now you know Peter vodka the
head of the IFC came from JP Morgan so
if you want to pry the sector guy you've
got a private sector guy I mean he was
not a guy who you know he'd done
commercial lending on a grand scale
donation he knows all about that stuff
so the idea that he doesn't get it
wasn't trying and so forth obviously
that would be wrong I think what has
happened the biggest thing that's
happened about the ISC and in the period
I cover is essentially that there was
this period when it was assumed that
look the private sector proper is going
to finance infrastructure the you know
the argentina argentina model of you
know privatizing telecoms privatizing
these utilities would be replicated
around the world somewhere bit slower
than argentina but essentially this was
you know the bank could get out of
infrastructure and this was compounded
by the desire to get out of
infrastructure because infrastructure
involves concrete that
involves environmental questions
therefore it involves huge political
risk with the civil society so for these
combined reasons both the bank's public
relations and this sort of late 90s
private sector boom the bank withdrew
from financing infrastructure and I
think that was a huge mistake if you
think about what is the niche of a
multinational lender like the world bank
with multi sectoral expertise which
spans engineering long-term financial
calculations in a macro economics
environmental impact studies you know
this is the World Bank and so I think
you know it's precisely for these big
infrastructure projects that the bank is
needed in the IFC ought to be at the
heart of that and they did take their
eye off the ball for a while because of
this perception of a private sector
taking the problem off their hands over
here and the aisle Eugene Marianne's
with cleary gottlieb steen and Hamilton
in Washington back to NGOs the Asian
Development Bank and other regional
development banks have began cooperating
with NGOs by giving them technical
assistance grants and other grants to
help them build development from the
ground up do you think the World Bank
has given enough attention to working
directly with NGOs helping fund them and
seeing what role they can play
particularly in socially oriented
programs yep the answer is that the
World Bank has done this enormously I
mean it's done masses of it it's done
enormous amounts of cooperation with
NGOs incredible focus on social projects
the the idea that it's no mainly doing
as I was saying before infrastructure
and these traditional black projects is
is kind of 20 years or 15 years out of
date so there's been every effort you
can imagine to participate with NGOs you
know do projects together with them give
them money so that they can be partners
and so forth you name it they've tried
it they tried it on a grand scale the
fact that they are still criticized by
NGOs show that the asian development
bank and the inter-american Development
Bank
kidding themselves if they think this
will buy them political cover it would
we've seen the case study with the World
Bank in the last decade there's a
question on the aisle here you know and
let me ask one quick one while the vikes
getting there so let's do the
counterfactual let's say that Jim
Wolfensohn wasn't president of the world
bank and Larry Summers the former
Treasury Secretary the president of
Harvard who also wanted the job had
gotten it would that have been different
better worse it would have been
different better and worse i do Michael
Gillette the private citizen retired
from free wolfensohn World Bank I hang
out hang out with people in financial
circles these days as to you you know
those folks like to criticize other
folks active in the in the financial
sector and Jim Wolfensohn has no
exception I don't think this is limited
to finance this no human behavior a
standard standard criticism is that
Wolfie rushed into transitioning Russia
and placed an enormous bit on the
success of the Russian transition which
now sits in the world bank's balance
sheet as a major threat how do you
assess the accusation that he did this
recklessly which is a word often used
and how do you appraise the Russian risk
in the bank's balance sheet that's a
good question i mean it's certainly true
that in early 95 when the clinton
administration was thinking about who it
should choose to run the world bank one
of the things on the administration's
mind was we need somebody who will do
what we want in Russia because Louie
Preston the previous president had been
rather reluctant to go finance Russia
for precisely the reasons that you
described and because the administration
had a you know wants to support yells
him they took the opposite view now when
Wolfensohn came in he did pour money in
there there were internal fights about
how much there was a quite a lot of
tension between him and some of his
lieutenants about you no one would say
okay I'm going to be tough and then he
would feel that the other one had never
done either whoever had the missing most
recently with Yeltsin was most likely to
have caved so you know and clearly in
retrospect this was a bad bet whether
prospectively it was so obvious I think
is difficult I mean you had to balance
the political risk of not supporting
Yeltsin obviously with a financial risk
of doing so and you know I think at the
time a lot of reasonable people would
have said this is a risk that the World
Bank ought to take it the world bank
doesn't take this kind of risk what's
the point of it you know we have this
institution so that we can make some
calls and on the on the residual effect
on the portfolio I didn't get the sense
at the bank that it's a big deal I mean
I think that you know unlike the IMF
which has made huge bets on three
countries turkey Argentina and Brazil
and is overexposed into a dangerous
extent at the World Bank is much more
diversified and less vulnerable to that
kind of thing one over here please and
then why doesn't the other might go to
the woman over there standing by the gun
don't like I'm Roger leads from Johns
Hopkins sighs ello hasn't been discussed
this morning the subtitle of your book
includes failed States as a topic I was
wondering how you would define that in
the context of the book and also the
extent to which the bank under Jim
Wolfensohn hazar has not effectively
addressed the problems of failed States
or how has he done it relative different
from other presidents in the past well I
mean is that there's a paradox about
about failed States which is that it's
precisely the concern with failed States
since nine eleven which is cause I think
an upsurge of interest in development
issues in Washington that's why we have
the Millennium Challenge account that's
maybe why we have the president's HIV
initiative on a bigger scale and that's
why the extreme animosity towards the
World Bank which is so in the first
couple of years of the Bush
administration or the first 18 months
maybe under paul o'neill has subsided to
a large degree and i don't think the
relations are cordial but there's no
longer this sort of constant effort to
denigrate and bash the the World Bank
which I think was the case early on so
you've had this sea change in the
broader foreign policy
community's interest in development
because of fails days and I mean just to
digress into history for a second this
is this is part of the pattern the World
Bank was created in 1944 at bretton
woods by FDR and the Allies because they
wanted to prevent a repeat of the 1930s
when hyperinflation and mass
unemployment had led to extremism in
Europe and war desperation had led to
desperate essence then the World Bank
was expanded greatly in 1960 with the
attacking arm of the soft learn window
why because in 1959 there was a Cuban
Revolution and there was the fear that
if we don't help these developing
countries they will go into the
Communist column and the classic
development text at the time was
Worcester stages of economic growth and
the subtitle was a non communist
manifesto so development and security
have always been linked up and whenever
security know that the geopolitical
kaleidoscope shifts a little bit and
people are more worried about failed
States that's when development gets more
attention now what does the bank do
about it that's the paradox rather
little its present in failed States all
the time but the central lesson about
development in the last ten years is
that basically aid works quite well
where you have a government that's
trying to do the right things is headed
in the right direction and you put money
in behind them and you accelerate their
progress aid is not terribly effective
where you have no good policies no good
institutions and things are falling
apart so you know there are certain
examples like Bosnia where you can have
had post-war breakdown where you can
sort of pick it up together again I
described that in some detail about how
the World Bank did this and it is a kind
of a romantic story late night David
said before of people flying into
broken-down sorry Ava airport on c-130
transports and running out of the back
to avoid the snipers but but to a
significant degree you know the bank's
role is actually you know the effect on
failed States is indirect it's by
accelerating the progress of the
countries that are making some progress
that you create an incentive for the
failed States to get their act together
and you insulate the better performing
poor countries from contagion by the
failed state next door and if you want
to protect
uganda from sort of suffering contagion
from sudan then you want to help you
gain by while it's on the right path and
accelerate its progress think we have
time for one question if you make it
story otherwise I get electrocuted vice
chairperson of the inspection panel at
the World Bank otherwise at Georgetown
University Law Center we haven't heard
anything about the participation of poor
people the voice of poor people why we
haven't heard anything about the values
of civil society as services as
viewpoints it must be considered or be
considered why what recommendations
would you have for making Development
effective at the local level to ensure
that development meets the needs of poor
people with their participation well in
my view you know all development efforts
which produce any kind of economic
progress in the country are good for
reducing poverty the correlation between
macro economic progress and poverty
reduction is really rather strong and so
to set up set up a dichotomy between you
know development on the one hand and
helping the poor on the other not
suggesting you necessarily did that but
some people do that and that is a
mistake now on poor people's voice the
World Bank has done a lot I mean the
idea as I was saying before that you
can't get a soft loan from the world
bank anymore unless you have a
participatory plan at which you know the
members of the local churches the
teachers the civil society of being
around the table helping to create the
national plan you don't get a learner
unless you've done that so so I mean
there's been enormous efforts to bring
the voice of the poor to the table and
in fact as you know there was an
enormous study called the voices of the
pole down under this leadership which
precisely tried to capture that that
that piece of it and I think that's been
a positive thing I think participation
you know hasn't always been a sort of
panacea but it's basically been on the
right track and so if I left that out
I'm sorry I didn't mean to but I thought
it was I I'm glad you asked the question
because we gave me an opportunity to
speak to it I think on that an addiction
will close I've been
to remind you that copies of the book
are for sale I think from politics and
prose out in the back and Sebastian will
be happy to autograph your copy at no
extra charge Sebastian malabi is a
columnist for The Washington Post the
world's banker is published by the
penguin press member of the penguin
group for more information visit their
website at penguin com next week on
public lives Reagan chief strategist
dick worthless